[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know my
name is c.a murray i'm in the company of
our founder our principal speaker and
director that is pastor stephen moore
pastor always good to be with you same
here yeah my my sister who watches this
program religiously donna says you know
you guys have such fun together you
actually look like you like each other
well the rumor is true we do indeed like
each other and enjoy each other's
company and we especially enjoy this
particular program because it gives us a
chance to answer your questions to study
the bible together and then come
together we have found though we don't
study together we don't huddle in the
room and go over the questions
assiduously no we actually study them
separately and then come together for
the program and we we find for the most
part pretty much all the time that uh
our thoughts are the same the the way we
approach bible study is the same so it's
fun to study uh with pastor bohr because
he's a student of the word and i try to
be a student of the word and our answers
always are in sync with another and i
appreciate that about amen
uh so
we want to promise you make you this
promise before i ask pastor lord of pray
whenever you send in a question and we
hope that you will send in your
questions because we like to answer them
that we will give you the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
from the word of god it's too late in
earth's history to
listen to and spend your time listening
to
the
rattlings of man you need to hear a word
from the lord and that's what we
promised to give you on this particular
program a word from the lord if an
answer can be found we will try to find
it and give it to you should you like to
send in a question
tv at some tv dot o r g is where you
send your questions tv at some tv.org
and we will try to answer them as best
we can pastor if you would pray then
we'll go to our first question and
we'll sort of start the program off
father in heaven we come before your
throne in humility
knowing that your wisdom is so far
surpassing ours amen and therefore as we
open your holy book we need your divine
guidance
so we ask for the presence of your
spirit and your angels with us in this
program
give us clarity of thought and give us
willing hearts
not only to believe these things
but to make them part of our lives amen
this we pray
in the precious and most holy name of
jesus
amen amen amen and amen
this question comes to us from india and
we are very very pleased to know that
pastor our footprint our reach goes to
as far as india we get questions from
europe south america africa uh of course
the united states all across this world
uh people are watching and are being
blessed by the offerings of some tv so
this one comes from sushil
from india she says i love she or he i'm
not sure
i love to watch tv
and some tv my question is
how can we assume
that daniel 7 verse 10 is the incident
of 1844.
please explain with regard to the
ancient of days did sit
so i guess we ought to make our way to
daniel chapter 7
and pick it up at verse 10. would you
like me to read it or do you want to
take that
before we read the text
i assume that the reason for the
question is
that you know who the judge is
and
you know the impression that i get from
the question is whether the judge is god
the father or whether the judge is
christ
and whether it applies to 1844 the
beginning of the investigative judgment
so before we read daniel 7 and verse 10
we need to understand that there's a
context to this verse oh yes
and if you look at the previous verses
you'll find that there's a lion
babylon there's a bear middle persia
there's a leopard greece
there's a dragon beast in rome
the dragon beast sprouts ten horns and
then among the ten horns rises a little
horn yes and so basically we've moved in
history
through babylon middle persia greece
pagan rome
divided rome
and then people people room also yes and
papal rome falls in the year 1798 yes
now the very next point in the sequence
is this verse yes so whatever is
happening in this verse has to be
happening after 18 after 1798 yeah which
1844 is after 1798 yes so let's read the
verse now
that's a very good way to to you've
pinpointed where we are in time we can't
be way way back uh we certainly are not
in the future uh so we we've sort of
locked ourselves into a time frame that
identifies where we are and that's the
thing about prophecy it allows you to
sort of read the street signs and know
where you are in the in in the stream
that's the historicist method precisely
there's a chain of events
one event after the other in
chronological order so you know exactly
where you are in the flow of prophetic
history
very very good all right verse 10 a
fiery stream issued
and came forth
from before him a thousand thousands
ministered to him
ten thousand times ten thousand stood
before him the court was seated and the
books were open so obviously we are
dealing with a judgment scene a judgment
scene that takes place post 1798 so
there are a number of little clues that
we can sort of nail down in trying to
figure out what we're looking at and the
time frame in which it falls absolutely
so very clearly this is taking place
after 1798 now right in the very next
chapter
is where you find daniel 8 14.
so daniel 7 gives us the event and the
approximate chronology but it does not
give us the date yes but when you go to
daniel chapter 8 it mentions that 2 300
days oh yes and then daniel 9 gives you
the first part of the 2 300 days which
is the 70 weeks
so then with daniel 8 and 9 you have the
precise date for the beginning of the
investigative judgment in heaven yes
you've got to put a number of things
sort of in the blender to get it nailed
down precisely but the pieces the pieces
to the puzzle are there you just got to
pull them from separate places and you
don't have to stray too far to do that
because in the next chapter 8 14 we find
under 2 300 uh days the sanctuary will
be cleansed um so that's another piece
of the puzzle we've got a judgment scene
we know it appertains to the cleansing
of the sanctuary and we've got a date
uh
300 days
brings us to 1844 i don't know if we got
time to do the whole math but certainly
we've got a date uh so we we can pretty
much lock this down to the event to
what's happening and to the date it
begins yeah and daniel 8 is basically
parallel to daniel 7. yes yes you don't
have all the identical elements but you
do have a ram which represents the mesen
persians you have a heat goat which
represents greece
and then you have a little horn which is
the same little horn of daniel chapter
and then after the little horn has its
period of dominion then you have uh the
2300 day prophecy unto 2300 days and the
sanctuary shall be cleansed so once
again the cleansing of the sanctuary
comes after the period of the dominion
of the little horn yes in daniel 8 as
well as in daniel 7. yes so if nothing
else we have we have really
i use the term nailed down the the date
the 1844. uh and we've nailed down if
you put the two chapters together
the event it's a judgment scene that
takes place beginning 1844. so we're
pretty solid on that because we've got
the biblic biblical evidence to
undergird it right now another question
related to this one and we're going to
answer it even though it's not explicit
in the question but it might be one of
the things that the person wants to know
and that is who is the judge in this
particular judgment you know daniel
chapter 7 says it's the ancient of days
yes which is god the father
but there are other texts that say that
the judge is jesus christ indeed
so we need to understand how
that is so let's go first of all to
we've already read in daniel 7 that the
ancient of days is the one that uh
presides in the judgment
but let's notice some other verses uh
ii corinthians chapter 5 and verse 10
which seems to say the opposite but it's
not really saying that we'll notice when
we put everything together
so
ii corinthians chapter 5 and verse 10
tells us you know whose judgment seat it
is yes for we must all appear before the
judgment seat of christ
that each one may receive the things
done in the body according to what he
has done whether good or bad and that's
what the book is books contain the
judgments sat in the books were open yes
here it says what the what the
books contained yeah the good and bad
things that we did yes
let's read also um john 5 verse 22.
john chapter 5 and verse 22 which is
pretty clear
pretty explicit
if you want to read that verse john
chapter 5 and verse 22 alrighty john 5
and i'm at 22
for the father judges no one
but has committed all judgment to the
son i think that's pretty clear it is
pretty clear indeed uh so why does why
is daniel 7 say that the father is the
one that goes for the judgment and here
these verses tell us that it's the son
well the good news is
that there's a verse that explains how
it works
let's go to acts 17 and verses 30 and 31
acts 17 30 and 31
and then i'll give you an analogy of
that helps explain this so acts 17 30
and 31 all right truly
these times of ignorance got overlooked
but now commands all men everywhere to
repent and 31 because he has appointed a
day
on which he will judge the world in
righteousness by the man whom he has
ordained he has given assurance of this
to all raising him from the dead
very interesting verse yes indeed
because it says that uh
there's a day that he that's talking
about god the father
he will judge the world in righteousness
but then it says by the man whom he has
ordained who is the man that he ordained
that's christ it's christ so the father
presides the judgment but jesus does so
to speak the nitty-gritty
and the analogy to this is you know who
who was the creator
uh you know the bible seems to say
sometimes that the father's the creator
sometimes the bible says that the son is
the creator so how do we understand this
well we read the text carefully yes so
let's go to the book of revelation
chapter four
revelation chapter four
and uh let's read verse 11. you know
there's one seated on the throne here
and the context clearly indicates that
it's god the father yes jesus isn't
there yet he comes comes there in
chapter five so read verse 11
you are worthy o lord to receive glory
and honor and power for you created all
things and by your will they exist and
were created now that's a very
interesting verse because it says about
the one on the throne you created all
things
but then the last part of the verse says
and by your will they exist yes
and were created that's passive voice
yes so it's somebody else is doing the
creating
so once again the idea here is that
creation was by god's will
through the instrumentality of the son
in other words the father was the
architect the one who devised the plan
yes and jesus was the one that
implemented the plan he actually did the
work itself yes so we can understand the
judgment in the same sense the father
presides the judgment and jesus is the
the active agent in the process of the
judge yes i think that that makes it
very clear that when you went to acts 17
that's what popped in my mind because
it's sort of the bridge text that brings
all
pieces together uh because in the
creation scene you've got you know
colossians without christ was not
anything made that was made so how do
you how do you fuse that together in
your mind right is that god did it
through the sun the same with creation
the same with judgment it's a very neat
little same through everything yes true
very true because ellen white says that
the father that jesus implemented the
father's will in the creation of all the
heavenly hosts yes yes so in other words
even when jesus created all the heavenly
beings
he did the work but the father was the
one who devised the plan yes and had him
do the work yes and and she also says
that uh one sin came into the world
almost exclusively all the dealings with
with the fallen human race was through
jesus christ so we understand that that
divine being at the bush was jesus
christ the i am that i am was jesus
christ so we find that god is working
through the sun and everything as you
rightly said is done through the sun so
it's it's it's a beautiful fusion of
missions and of accomplishing the work
that god wanted to do illinois
has an amazing statement where she says
what speech is to thought
so is christ to the eternal father yes
yes so what she's saying is that the
father thinks
and then the son does what the father
thinks yes yes
so the father devises the plan in his
infinite mind
he shares the master plan with the sun
and then the sun actually
does the work yeah so so they work very
closely together that's a beautiful
fusion i like that very much let's read
hebrews 1 1 and 2 it comes to mind
before we go on to the next question
hebrews chapter one verses one and two
here you have once again in creation the
father working through the son
so let's uh let's have you read hebrews
chapter one
and verses one and two
god who had various times and in diverse
ways in various ways i'm thinking king
james
ways spoke in times past to the fathers
by the prophets has in these last days
spoken to us by his son whom he has
appointed heir of all things through
whom he hath made the worlds
yeah so
who made the world yeah jesus did what
god did through this side has made the
world through jesus
in other words they work very closely
together you remember at the tomb of
lazarus that jesus prayed to his father
he says i thank you that you've heard me
even before you resurrected lazarus
i thank you that you've heard me
and ellen way commenting on that states
that the reason why jesus said that is
because he wanted all of those present
to know that he did not work
independently from his father yes that
they worked harmoniously together
and so you know jesus doesn't say to the
father well why do i always have to do
the work
[Laughter]
he joyfully performs the will of the
father amen and that teaches us a lesson
even the most menial things that we have
to do that god asks us to do we should
do them joyfully we should do them
willingly yes yes i read just this week
you know it was actually just last week
or week before elohim says
sanctification this is in the morning
watch for this this this year of
sanctification is the the cheerful
expedition or cheerful doing of little
tasks giving us given us daily by the
father that's part of the sanctifying
experience to cheerfully throw yourself
into those tasks
not because they're big not because
they're great not because someone will
applaud your work but simply because
they are fulfilling of god's will for
your life right that's part of
sanctification amen
okay now we have another question here
this one
comes from anna
and a lugube
and
the question is this
is it true
that earth will be the new headquarters
of the universe
in revelation 21 22
in revelation 21 22 since the lord god
almighty and the lamb
will be in the new jerusalem which will
come down to earth
so the father and the son are going to
be in the new jerusalem and the new
jerusalem comes down to earth
so here's the question what will happen
to the present heaven
where
god jesus
and his angels live
interesting question
very much so
um
let me throw out an overarching answer
heaven
my pastor my friend
is where god is
and wherever god is is heaven
so um
i've got a reading from a great
controversy there's a lot in here and i
didn't bring it all where she says the
holy the holy city of the new jerusalem
which is the capital and representative
of the kingdom of god uh
of the kingdom is called the bride
uh the lamb's wife
so she goes on and and there there's
much here
to talk about the new jerusalem coming
here and it will be the capital yeah um
there is a new heaven and a new earth
there's going to be a brand new earth
because the the old one is destroyed
through fire and cleansed through fire
but there's going to be some changes in
heaven too
uh one of which is not gonna be a temple
uh a sanctuary experience because it's
no longer necessary um so there's gonna
be some changes but uh if god
moves the heavenly host to
earth
then
that's heaven yeah that's the new
capital so basically what's going to
happen is where he was is left vacant
it's like you know
uh in ancient times they used to move
houses
i think in new orleans they still do
that you know
they take the houses they have a very
sophisticated way of lifting the house
yes and moving it to another place so
what happens when they move the house
with the old place yeah well it's bacon
it's vacant right so let's go to the
bible and see what the bible has to say
let's go to hebrews chapter 11 verse 10.
i'm there hebrews chapter 11 and verse
10 to see what's the expectation of
abraham and all of the old testament
heroes that's a nice way to approach it
i'm in verse 10 of hebrews chapter 11
verse 9 verse 7. for he waited
the the king james has looked for a city
which has foundations whose builder and
maker is god so what city would that be
that god built that'd be the earthly
jerusalem no sir has to be the new
jerusalem
and then let's read verse 16. it's
talking once again about all those old
testament heroes and what they look
forward to
but now they desire a better
that is a heavenly country therefore god
is not ashamed to be called their god
for he hath he has prepared a city for
them and once again that city is
the new jerusalem
now is the new jerusalem going to come
down here you know
before we answer that question
uh
jesus made two promises to his people
well he made many promises but two
relating to this specific topic that
we're dealing with
he promised to take us to heaven
right yes
in john 14 1 1-3 he said in my father's
house how many mansions if it were not
so i would have told you i go to prepare
a place for you and if i go and prepare
a place for you i will come again and
receive you to myself that where i am
you may be also so he promised to take
his followers to heaven yes
but then he also promised the meek will
inherit the earth
so what is it going to be
is that heaven or is it the north well
the fact there is there is no
contradiction because for a thousand
years yes he's going to take us to the
new jerusalem in heaven
and then after the thousand years the
new jerusalem is going to descend with
the father and the son yes and
probably the cherubim seraphim because
they're there and god is going to make
this
world
the capital of the entire universe
that is a mind-boggling thought it is
very much so
very much so what a privilege
uh let's read also revelation you know
to put the icing on the cake so to say
uh revelation chapter 22
21 1 and 2 first of all
actually let's read uh
21 verse 2.
okay
um
in verse 3.
okay well i'll read 21 22 okay
21 1 through 3. there you go now i saw a
new heaven and a new earth for the first
heaven and the first
first earth had passed away so
there they're gone and there was no more
sea sin
then i john saw the holy city new
jerusalem coming down out of heaven from
god prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and three
and i heard a loud voice from heaven
saying behold the tabernacle of the
dwelling place of god is with men and he
will dwell with them and they shall be
his people god himself will be with them
and be their god
so is the new jerusalem going to descend
to this earth and is god going to be
here according to these verses according
to his verses yes he's going to be with
us yes
uh and let's read 22 1-3 as well chapter
22 and verses 1 to 3.
this is now
on the new earth the new jerusalem is on
the on the
renewed earth right renewed earth is a
better way to put it and he showed me a
pure
river of water of life clear as crystal
proceeding from the throne of god and of
the lamb in the middle of its streets
and on each on either side of the river
was the tree of life which bore twelve
fruits each tree yielding its fruit
every month
the leaves of the tree were for the
healing of the nations and verse three
and there shall be no more curse but the
throne of god and the lamb shall be in
it and his servants shall serve him
so very clearly born of god and of the
land that's the key we're going to be in
the new jerusalem here on earth yeah so
we go back to
my original point is
heaven is where god is and if god
chooses to trans
plant if i can use that terminology
heaven to the new earth and so be it uh
wherever god is that is heaven of course
i can also add wherever god is that's
where we want to be
that's what i'm wearing
in the stratosphere or right here on the
brand new earth that's where we want to
be and that's where we will be that is
the the the privilege that mankind will
will entertain throughout eternity that
this earth the scene of the crime as it
were is going to be the the scene of the
the new kingdom forever and ever that's
that's a mind-boggling thought yeah yeah
sure is you know that god
would make this little speck of a world
i mean we can't even call it a speck
yeah
you know it's
in the context of the entire universe
it's almost like an invisible speck true
and that god
would make this planet
the capital
of the universe forever and ever and
we're going to live here
it boggles the mind it boggles my mind
anyway it it it is a mind-boggling
thought
and and and and given the fact that from
this small speck of dust we will have
access to the entire universe
i suspect no place we cannot go no place
we cannot cannot understand what's going
on there i mean mankind is spending
billions of dollars
i was listening to what they're spending
just to get this rocket to go to the
edge of space turn around come right
back down
i think 17 minutes from liftoff to
splashdown
billions of dollars of money and we are
going to be able to transport ourselves
wherever the lord will allow us to go is
a is a
it's a it is a mind-boggling thought
there's another way to put it
you know uh we say we've conquered space
yes because we went to the moon
well we've gone to the moon with people
and to mars without people right
and we say wow
how great man is look he's gone to the
moon and this uh whatever
you know piece of equipment went to mars
and we brag but
where is the throne of god now it's in
the depths of orion yes
and you know there has to be a dimension
of speed that we're not acquainted with
because they're true because to travel
from here
to heaven
in just a few days in seven days
according to the spirit of prophecy
you know that's a pretty quick trip to
it so far
[Laughter]
indeed it is so uh you know the main
thing is that we're on that trip yeah
when you sit
and and ponder these things first of all
that makes you very humble
that god has
done so much for us has
prepared so much for us and wants so
desperately to have us to be with him
that he is not happy he will not heaven
will not be complete until the wayward
children are home it's a humbling
humbling thought that the god of the
universe cares that much about us and
identifies with us so very very much
yeah yeah you know we're talking about
speed
uh daniel was praying for light
on the 2300 days yes i know where you're
going the bible tells us that gabriel
said to him you know you know when you
started your prayer i was on my way
very true but if he says his prayer
guess what yeah gabriel is there so it's
it's another dimension that we don't
know
you know because we're we're limited by
space and time
um it's going to be fantastic there are
so many things physicists are finding so
many things
you know our our brains now can only
process so much
we our brains will be expanded we'll get
the full use you know there's large
centers of our brain that we don't even
have access to anymore we can't they're
just kind of sitting there because we
can't get into that part of our own
heads right i think all of that will be
actuated in the new man in the new earth
so there's so much that we can learn and
so many ways to to learn knowledge and
so much to learn right
let me do just in the few seconds we
have there's this house cleaning item
here
do you have a pdf of the literary
structure of revelation 12 to 22.
that was our anchor class the study
notes for anchor class this year
the person says i was watching stephen
board from the close of probation to the
new earth
is this available in pdf is the question
of the chart
and the answer is yes all you have to do
is contact secrets unsealed
and
you can get a pdf copy of that so that
you can use it in teaching others well
thank you so much for joining us our
time is up god bless you hope to see you
next time on i'd like to know
[Music]
you